[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just
[Music]
reach out
[Music]
like
[Music]
darkness
the balance
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I only know one truth
it's time for the Jedi to end
[Music]
when I found you I saw raw untamed power
and beyond that
something very special
[Music]
something beside me has always been
[Music]
but I was awake
[Music]
[Music]
I've seen this roster only once before
too scared me enough that
it doesn't know
[Music]
for the pastime
kill it
if you have to
that's the only way to become what
you're meant to be
[Music]
[Applause]
we are the fire
[Music]
this is not going to go
[Music]
where you think
destiny
I need someone to show me my place in
all this
[Music]
everybody starts episode eight gosh the
first film didn't even have a number
Ryan has written a story that's
unexpected but right
[Music]
some of the stuff that happens people
gonna be not oh my god
even though I think I know it all they
throw things at me story wise I never
could have imagined and even though
everybody knows it's the second in a
trilogy it feels like its own thing
Star Wars is so cool because there's all
these creatures
amazing visual effects
but all the characters are also so
complex
why in Mesa welcomes wiki South's
particular new director only business
line or key sound
[Music]
it feels like the storylines become more
established
we're really getting to know these new
characters also with the characters that
we know and love
may life's change
everything is being shifted in the
opposite way to what the audience
expected after 7:00
Brian's made Star Wars fresh in you
I'm hoping it'll be a little shocking
but I'm hoping it'll feel real and
honest
the fermentation story of it against
evil
hold in the most fascinating way but it
has a real spiritual depth to it
it's about family and that's what's so
powerful about it
walking up the ramp walk into the
hallway I flashback to when I was a kid
and with the action figures inside
suddenly I had like a big lump in my
throat
Brian is doing many unexpected things
and taking characters in new directions
individual stories of these characters
are elevated and made fresh and new
that's what I love about Ryan's approach
to the story it's like a real journey of
discovery
he's and gentlemen welcome to episode 8
[Music]
first time shooting with mark the first
time Shane with Daisy
first time shooting a Star Wars movie
and we've got some little stuff
sad like a dog whimper Ryan's wonderful
personality is all over this phone
I've misjudged this he has flaws in
other areas I just don't know about
there's the weird thing that happens
mines being built and when you first
show up on it here's kind of over about
ropes by at all and then you get into
the nitty-gritty of working on it ready
and action
naturally that level of it goes away and
you find yourself just focus on making
the scene work getting the shots and
then once in a while you're taking a
little break and sitting back and you
look around
to get the holy crap mountain again
concentrators works split up by holy
craps
[Music]
beautiful and very nice guys your
animatronics puppetry physical effects
yeah looks fantastic this is a little
evolution of the crystal fox
[Music]
and we'll do a combination of a hand
puppet they'll be animatronics in the
face
and then we will make a perfect version
for CG I will then scan it to be able to
bring her to life in any way the Ryan
Ones
[Music]
physically I never really had to push
myself that hard and stamina wise you're
like oh my god
it's like a psychological thing of
knowing that you can do it more and more
and more daizy is training for a moment
where she is on the islands and she has
a moment to herself and she's practicing
with the staff and then she realizes
what am I wasting my time practicing
with the staff I have Luke Skywalker's
lightsaber in my satchel it's just
working out the moves for that action
[Music]
I was a planning teacher her the whole
routine in three days but she
surprisingly then everything in an hour
she's a very quick learner
[Music]
this is the hardest physical thing I've
done yet
the suit can be very restrictive just to
move in just to walk in you do the move
and you think gosh is it lunchtime yet
finem phasma ended up face to face which
results in a major fight one thing I do
want to do is do the whole fight by
myself there's really good scene to
shoot very tiring her
what was cool was learning different
types of fighting was intense and fun a
really hard training yesterday was great
and then today we started an artist Leo
I was watching out him and he gives it
so full out every single time I mean it
was kind of like oh my god I can do that
I can do that
it's just rigorous in a great way and
these stunt guys are very disciplined so
you can't half-ass it
the stunt team are absolutely amazing
they've got my boys and us
[Music]
you don't have expression you don't have
a voice you don't have a face very
understandable they came to me and said
we have a bunch of guys who are coming
in to be robot waiters which you maybe
talk to them about your experience
isolating it to your body
tightening up in the middle because if
your machine you can't really all
willowy it is so good we had such fun on
set here's how you triangulate off
different objects to say yes I'm on my
mark the guys were great and they really
really worked hard over and over again
[Music]
first conversations you have are always
about what makes something feel like
Star Wars this is the most massive
production I've ever worked on
they've outdone themselves internal
assists
it makes me feel like I'm on another
planet every other day we're gonna do
incredible location Croatia was the
perfect place to shoot canto bites
we're in this alleyway into growth Nick
smashing speeders that's just one of
those oh my gosh whether we doing this
is amazing lemons
the other big new world is crates we
shot in Bolivia on the salt flats he's
got his red mineral covered with salt
flakes that gives it a sort of a white
blank canvas
what would a battle on a planet like
that look like
[Music]
we also shot on skellig michael off the
coast of ireland
it's very wish the Brooklyn skilling
shooting eight here we go it was really
nice to put Luke Skywalker in front of a
camera
and turn
all right good come on you've never seen
anything like this
there's just this magical feeling that
you get and you're transported to
another world we are working in pretty
high places dangerous places I think
it's worth it because everything is
gorgeous
[Music]